foreign
Jeff is in Canada hi Jeff welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi Jess uh sorry I uh
um yeah hi hi how can we help what's up
man
um so I'm in a pretty bad buying
uh I screwed up and uh now I'm about
give or take thirty seven thousand
dollars in debt
paycheck
and a good part of my debt is actually
my old business and more specifically my
older employees
um I haven't been sleeping well for a
while now and I just I want to get out
of this
I want to honor them
although I haven't done it for Less two
years but I just want to fix everything
and uh
yeah
wow you've been hit with a lot so you've
got the uh
I mean I closed the business and went
broke so I know how that feels that you
feel ashamed on top of that I didn't pay
my bills or my bankrupt so I felt double
ashamed and on top of that you've got
employees that you love that you owe
money to so you got another dose of
Shame uh so you you got a lot hanging on
your shoulders don't you
yeah
um
I decided to fight to not go bankrupt by
purpose because I knew I well you're
gonna pay them anyway because they're
your friends
pardon you're going to pay them anyway
because they're your friends even if you
went bankrupt right
they most of them were my friends until
yeah sorry
um
and
I'm
it's just getting worse and worse and
what do you make what do you make now
uh right now I work remote uh for 2400 a
month
well that sucks uh take home uh take
home so that's with the deductions yeah
that sucks
um
but I had a second job earlier this
winter but I was uh I was uh I laid off
and I can't get a second job I've been
hunting for one bit
um I don't have a car anymore because
part of my bed is also blocking my
license from from me being able to
travel so I can travel but I can't I
need a car because I live in real rural
area
so part of the part of the settlement
against your debt is that you can't go
get work somewhere else that doesn't
make any sense
it's like an old debtor's prison back
from the Dark Ages
in our Province if you owe anything for
traffic tickets and some of those
traffic tickets were from our old bus
and my old drivers and me had signs and
the owner of the company gets a fine as
well as a driver if there's anything
wrong even if it's speeding the owner of
the company gets a fine as well all
right
okay so
you you you're talking to two guys who
in various stages have been right where
you are
okay
and so the question I'm going to ask you
on behalf of both of us is first I'm
going to say
it feels like everything is in a dark
cloud
absolutely you're not crazy
the question I'm going to ask you is
this
do you want to do what it takes
to begin scratching and clawing and
sprinting your way out of this thing
I've been trying to because I went for a
second job earlier no I got you I got
you but but part of saying yes I want to
scratch and Claws saying okay the way I
was doing it wasn't working I want to
try something else would you be willing
to do that
yeah okay you've got two issues here one
is and you have in your mind they've all
turned into one big toxic stew
one of the issues is you got to get
these debts paid off
the second is yeah like so it's a math
problem you got a finance issue and the
second thing is is you've got so much
shame so much relationship dysfunction
and now you're working from home so you
just sit by yourself all day long and
still it's doing students do and you
faced rejection and you got laid off all
this stuff so you got this interpersonal
stuff going on this relationship stuff
right so these are two separate
challenges here so we got a plan for you
to help you with the money
but you're gonna have to take someone I
would consider some pretty radical steps
on The Human Side of this would you be
willing to do that
yeah and I I forgot to say earlier that
I've been looking at getting uh loan
to try and Tackle one of the two
and just get rid of one of the two
problems I mean problems
um so I was also calling about that
afternoon I should get along and fight
for it no you have an income problem
we have to solve that we have to solve
your income problem you can't borrow
your way out of debt
and the bad news is you have 37 000
worth of debt the great news is it's not
370 000 it's only thirty seven thousand
dollars three thousand dollars a month
for a year and you're free
you're completely free but you don't
make any money
and you've got a thousand reasons why
you have to stay in this poop that
you're sitting in and I'm going to tell
you you probably need to move to another
city and get six jobs in the city
and that you can't sit in a rural
community where there's no jobs and make
twenty four hundred dollars in a dark
room and get out of this
besides that you need the human
interaction you need the sunlight
yeah yeah and you need a new look a new
a new a fresh start
and I don't know if you moved back to
this community someday later but I want
you to go 100 miles away and move into a
major city and I want you to work seven
jobs 80 hours a week and I want you to
be a hundred percent debt free by this
time next year with fifteen thousand
dollars in the bank then you've got some
choices